there's this new thing now where you
just can criticize your man or criticize
your person or someone comes home and
it's like so you're just going to walk
in the door and not say hi positive
reinforcement is pretty much I believe
the only thing that works and I think
that I'm not seeing it on either side
right now with men or women if like your
girl comes home and she's rough or she's
going out with her friends too whatever
it is instead of getting in a fight
about it like just you know what I love
like I love when you come home I come
home and you're here and you're like on
the couch and you're Barefoot it's just
the sexiest thing in the world and like
kiss her on the forehead and just see if
if anything changes IID don't like that
he wears this thing when he wears the
other thing just tell him how hot it is
and suck
his why is this so hard to understand I
just think that for every criticism we
have it just try positive reinforcement
try that you know what I love I love
when your phone is off and I just get to
like as opposed to why do you always
have your phone out on the table it
always makes me so annoyed that's it
don't even say that one just when
there's no phone out take that
opportunity to tell him how great it is